do you need medical attention no I'm
good please please she has she's over
there she has a
baby stay here with her no no no move
away move
away ma'am I'm right here I'm okay I I
know you're not going anywhere can you
put your phone up for a second please
what's your name oh my
God I'm sorry I'm trying to take video
proof please find my home girl please I
need you to tell me your name before we
before we go to anything else what's
your
name so why were you guys fighting
because I
want she's overthinking things what do
you mean she's overthinking between me
and her husband and I don't have nothing
to do with her husband all I was doing
was on the phone my mom while he was
outside smoking a cigarette and she was
thinking me and him were doing something
while I was on the pH my mom okay are
you guys all staying here yes we are
okay and I had the baby the whole time
and she came after you while you had the
baby yes okay so where's the baby now
she hit me while I had the baby while I
was carrying the baby okay so where is
where's the baby now that's what I'm
trying to find out but y'all not fucking
letting me take off and look for the
baby no we're not letting you take off
we needed you to tell us which way she
went please at least go look for her
please can calm down and tell me which
way she went no I can't calm down cuz
it's a 9-year-old month baby okay old
figure out which way did she go she took
off right over there please all right
have a seat right here tell the offic
I'm okay I'm good she's the one that hit
me first okay yeah that's why I wanted
hey hey look at me listen listen that's
why I'm just looking at your injuries
okay that's all that's all that's going
on right now right
okay
here have a seat take a breath take a
breath we got listen listen we got three
officers over there looking all right
all right can I ask you what room number
you're in
ma'am hey we're fucking in trouble M
like um oh fuck
like yeah she fucking she hit me in the
fucking face I hear her back why I was
holding AEL bro like she's fucking out
of there mad as fuck saying that me and
you with something else I don't fucking
know what the fuck is going on in her
head bro but it's fucked up like I'm
with the cops right now I'm with the
cops legit right
now they're fucking I don't know they
just fucking asking too many fucking
questions looking for Mariah apparently
they fucking have her and
shit but they're questioning me cuz I
got her blood on me and
shit we're just talking to you right now
man we're just trying to figure out what
went on Mariah took off with ail she
fucking took off with him she was
fucking mad as soon as we legit
supposedly got out of the camera she she
legit to yanked him out of me my hands
and fucking took off with him talking
about that's her fucking baby and shit
whose baby is it it's her baby okay
dude I don't know where she's at I don't
know all right I got it all right I got
you just check me
please all right babe
bye all right so Alexander this is what
I need from you all right I need you
just tell me what went on like what's
going on right now really what just
happened me and her just had a
disagreement that's she like your sister
or yeah she's my sister she's my sister
that's all it was it was just a
disagreement okay but she just really
felt very offended and I I understand
her part but it just never it never
played off like that I promise it never
played off like that okay so she got mad
at me the baby started crying I picked
him up she's telling me she's going to
leave I'm like how are you going to
leave keep in mind we're all from
another state you know mhm so what state
y'all from U we're just from other state
and she took the baby out what like what
state specifically well really we
just can I tell you a story yeah but
like just what state are yall from all
yeah sure go ahead so um she just she
just took off with the baby really it
was just a disagreement she just felt
offended it was just off all right cool
Alexander what do you have an idea
anywhere near you probably not okay so
what state are you from I'm from Texas
from Texas okay you mind give me like
your full name real quick I don't I
don't really want to well you don't
really have a choice like you have to
identify yourself I don't have to no
Alexandra I'm going to save you
potentially some trouble right now it's
Florida state law listen to me Alexander
listen to me cuz I've been very
courteous with you I've been very
courtious with you I just Sheen we'll
let you know that okay we want to thank
Morgan and Morgan for sponsoring this
body cam video I mean I think it's
pretty clear from the body cams that we
covered that it's not always safe out
there when you're hurt it can be
confusing it can be scary you don't
really know where to turn well Morgan
and Morgan is actually the largest
injury law firm in America and in a time
when you already have so much to think
about they're going to make it super
easy for you they have completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents you talk to your whole
legal Team all on your phone that's it
an attorney is going to review your case
in just eight clicks also they have
4,000 support staff that can help you
too which is just amazing to think about
and in terms of price well you only pay
them if you win there's no upfront fee
so if you're injured and you want to
join the over 3 million people that call
them every year you can submit a claim
at www. forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone but you
have to identify yourself okay I already
didra okay I need to know your full
name where is she can you at least tell
me I'll be happy to tell you that as
soon as you give me your name I do you
do no
I'm can you please tell me where she
said where are you are hey hey hey can
you hang up no no I'm asking you to give
us phone oh no God oh my God why are you
acting like that you don't put your
hands on me you don't put your hands on
me I didn't put put my hands on you stop
resisting and follow instructions why
are you acting like that towards me stop
pulling away from me yes you
are I'm not no please don't I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm not I'm
[Music]
not you need to stop resisting tensing
up I
promise
oh no no
sorry I would okay have a seat
Alexandra but I would have a seat have a
seat have a seat now Alexander I have a
bad leg hold on I have a bad
[Applause]
leg are you primary
I wasn't res oh you actually
were yeah you still got my Pat thank
you that's what I tried to S save the
trouble of happening but I I didn't
between you not wanting to give your
name you tensing up you pull away from
me and on top of that you grabbed my
arm and I know that don't fly in Texas
and it sure I don't fly here but like no
there ain't no butt like disect there
ain't no but like hey man did I I I
don't know I was trying to
find 86 I got 1150 heit where is she at
least can I at least know she's safe
that's all you need to know right now
but like is she like where is she is she
in the cop car where's the baby where's
the baby she is safe and the baby is
safe with her where is the baby you
don't need to know that right now pleas
I do I'm very
worried my God no I really hope I really
hope you gave me your real name you
don't got to tell me shit I really hope
you gave me your real name if I
if I touched your hand I'm sorry I
didn't mean to okay well that's that's
why you're in cuffs right now okay I get
it nigga like God DN like come on now
like Alexandria how do you spell your
first
name I'm sorry I know this is f but I
really don't want to talk you're kind of
you're no but I have the right to not
that's absolutely fine that's another
charge charge identif obstruction that's
another charge so keep
going do you have a middle name I
don't not only that they won't let you
out of jail until you physically
identify yourself we'll book you under
Jame do and you'll stay there as long as
it
takes so have it your
[Music]
way
you're only Mak the baby safe I would
like to know I would love to know if the
bab okay right now you need to answer
the questions that we're asking you yeah
but I there's officers with to know if
the baby sa yes the baby is safe I told
you that a few minutes ago but like
where is he can I speci that right now
that doesn't matter like but is he what
matters right now is you identifying
yourself you need to identify yourself
okay just book her under Jane do and
she'll stay at the jail for as long as
it takes that's
fine so that's what we just going to
doal with just it's another charge and
the but that's how I want to play off
right I'm just trying to play it's not
playing no but I'm this is how it's
happening all I'm asking is where's the
baby I told you the baby asking you to
identify yourself for a long time who is
the baby with with an officer with an
officer
[Music]
like I said right now that's irrelevant
right now this okay done it's that
simple and if she doesn't identify
herself book her under Jane do and she
won't be able to be released right
that's it she had every chance in the
world time to
go I'll grab her
phone that's what's up though hope you
get catching extra charges that's what's
up sounds real
cool I'm going to put this on your front
seat okay I don't have shit on me
bro I was literally got run out of the
hotel
room nice fucking
nice you got my my my phone right yeah
please yours like over you got to put a
seat belt on me too okay do me a favor
Lean Back do me a favor lean back thank
you for real yeah for real for real yes
for real what happens when you don't
identify yourself in the State of
Florida who are
you is it your child I'm a stepdad okay
so we need to get some information from
yes this is the stepdad I guess I'm the
step heard the other party's name no not
yet Alexandra Sal salivar that's her
best friend and her her name is Mariah
Salazar they've been honestly they've
been jealous my wife has been jealous
that I'm missing with her friend but
I've I've been pure myself and they just
having their I don't know arguments she
called me they said she said she had a
fight I was hanging out to Duval and oh
so you weren't here for this whole no I
mean I was earlier here when they were
arguing I was like I'm out of here like
you know cuz she I mean she slapped me
in my face slightly I'm going to
pressing in Char she's my wife and as
soon as I she touched my my face I was
little you know I was little drinking I
was out and she calls me like an hour
later and she tells me that cops there
took me like about 45 minutes to walk
here what I already identified myself
with one officer y'all have cameras
right okay y'all can look back at are
you going to can I talk to you for a
second of course cooperating but I'm
you're not cooperating at all but like
you have to understand I'm very worried
okay if you'll listen to me for a minute
we ran your name the name you gave us
and nothing came back so that's why I
was confirming the spelling and
everything was was correct and you
refused to give it to me so guess what
look at my chain I got my name on my
neck look this is for my education could
we release the baby to a step parent
yeah if I mean they're they're legally
married so I mean she would he would be
a legal guardian yeah
and then I think I didn't know if there
was something is the I think the is her
your wife's mother here with y'all too
grandma left yesterday okay so who who's
all in the room it's me her Alexandra
and Azrael which is the infant the baby
okay
yes and you all you all live together
yeah we all live together we came here
for like a business trip SL vacation
we're checking out a sandb bar for sale
here actually and uh the babies the
baby's coffee shop and we're here like
for three
[Music]
nights man' you want to tell me what
happened me and my friend got into an
application
and into a f b the baby was asleep
and he woke up I pretty much tried to
take her away from him and we fought
[Music]
she so the baby woke up while you guys
were
fighting okay what started this
fight
jealousy okay and then how did it
start arguing case you were arguing and
then what happened about a past
situation you arguing about a past
situation and then one thing to
another one thing led to another and my
baby woke up she got him off the bed and
then I ended up like getting him from
her
sir and then that's when security came
and he
cops
came
[Applause]
water can you spread your you get there
once they get in they'll get you some
water
yes
okay okay she's good okay thank
you one for the books
bitch KY West that's what the fuck it is
nigga oh fuck
F
fuck can I at least know why I'm going
in for battery and for
resisting battery what the what did I
County want to throw fale on board cop
beginning battery I'm sorry can you
repeat
it
21987 you said battery I didn't have no
item on me or
anything advised the jail that we'll be
coming with two female 105s they're
going to be key
boys
that's all you right that's all you
bit hey you said battery and resistance
right yep what's battery I'm sorry it's
in Texas they might the same thing as AA
ass
Sal I'm sorry ass
Sal what Assa assult on
what on your friend ass on my
friend really so I was the